was ist diesmal Frau Amiri an diesem
Protesten anders
es wurde schon oft im Iran protestiert
aber das was jetzt passiert ist sind
keine Proteste mehr es ist ein
Revolution das ist eine Absage an das
politische System die Menschen wollen
die Islamische Republik nicht mehr sie
rufen Tod der Islamischen Republik Tod
dem Diktator und sie sagen dieses Jahr
ist das Jahr das Blut ist und das
Sturzes von Harmony das ist eine ganz
klare Ansage es gibt keine
Verhandlungsmasse mehr wir wollen keine
Reformen es geht nicht ums Kopftuch es
geht um das große Ganze wir wollen einen
grundlegenden politischen Wandel wir
fallen nicht mehr auf eure Tricks
reingefallen nicht mehr auf eure
Angebote es gibt Reformen und dann kommt
wieder zur Wahl ohne kommt wieder zur
Wahl das machen wir nicht mehr mit wir
haben euer Spiel durchschaut eine
Kollegin von mir die in Peking
Korrespondentin für die bereit ist
schrieb in ihrem letzten Artikel das
totalitäre Regime ganz gerne ein X für
ein U verkaufen wollen und das auch tun
im Iran glauben die Menschen diesem X
für ein U verkaufen nicht mehr sie
glauben den Regime nicht mehr
wo du sie sind mittlerweile gemeinsam
mit ihrem Mann nach Deutschland geflogen
vielleicht zu Beginn der die Frage wie
haben Sie das gemacht wir haben Sie das
geschafft ich weiß dass man ihn auf der
Schliche war sie sind entgegen den
Auflagen zu einer neuen Demonstration
gegangen sie und ihr Mann ihr Mann hat
Sicherheitsbeamte in Zivil gefilmt aber
die haben ihrerseits auch ihnen gefilmt
und wenige Tage später kriegten sie
Besuch Wohnung besucht alles auf den
Kopf gestellt in die Wohnung
eingedrungen und sie haben sich
entschlossen zu fliegen die haben Sie
das gemacht
[Musik]
passiert ist ist für mich und viele
andere Frauen ähnliches passiert
mit Massa passiert ist wo ich mit meinem
Neffen unterwegs wir wollten zu einem
Vergnügen soll eigentlich war ich nicht
angezogen auf dem Rückweg bin ich von
der Polizei festgenommen worden und ich
bin in ein Mann mit Zwang geklärt worden
ich hatte ich hatte ihm gesagt ich habe
gesagt ich habe Angst in so ein Auto
einzustellen aber ich bin unter Zwang
ähm musste ich einsteigen ich hatte sehr
viel Angst gehabt ich habe
Herzrasen gehabt und ich habe gedacht so
viel gefallen so viel Gewalt nur weil
ich weil mein Mantel kein weil meine
Mantel einen Knopf fehlte als Macher das
konnte ich das so nachvollziehen aus
ganzem Herzen konnte ich das
nachvollziehen weil ich wusste weil ich
das nachvollziehen konnte was da
passiert ist was dazu geführt hat dass
sie so aufgeregt war an dem Abend als
sie gestorben ist war ich da ich war
draußen ich war vor dem Krankenhaus ich
habe so viele Frauen gesehen ich habe so
viele Frauen gesehen die aus Solidarität
mit Wasser da waren wir hatten alle ein
gemeinsamen Schmerz wir haben ein
gemeinsames Leid gehabt vielleicht muss
man ihre Geschichte noch einmal ganz
kurz in in ein paar Eckpunkten
zusammenfassen damit man versteht was da
wirklich passiert ist 23 August der
Abend den Sie gerade schildern sie sind
auf offener Straße unterwegs werden in
ein Auto gezerrt von diesem sogenannten
Sittenwächtern weil wie sie gerade
erzählt haben ein Knopf ihres Mannes
offen war das war sozusagen das einzige
vergehen sie werden verhört sie werden
erniedrigt dann kommt dieser 16
September Gina massamiri stirbt und dann
25 September sind sie wieder mit ihrem
Mann bei einer Demonstration in Rast ich
glaube 300 Kilometer von Teheran
entfernt werden verhaftet ins Gefängnis
geworfen und dann kommt der Teil den die
Weltöffentlichkeit glaube ich so mit
Ausnahme von Natalia Miriam Weltspiegel
so noch nicht gehört hat vor allen
Dingen war noch nie jemand bereit offen
also ohne verfremdet zu sein ohne
verpixelt zu sein wie wir das im
Fernsehen nennen aber noch nie jemand
bereit das öffentlich auf großer Bühne
zu erzählen 12 Tage Einzelhaft sie
wurden geschlagen sie wurden verhört und
sie sagen ich habe mich die ganze Zeit
gefragt was machen die mit mir bringen
die mich um was war das für eine
Situation wie war diese Situation im
Gefängnis
[Musik]
ich hatte furchtbare Tage dort
Tagung Nächte voller Einsamkeit voller
Angst ich wusste nicht was mir passieren
wird jeden Augenblick habe ich gedacht
sie kommen und sie werden mich töten
sie haben mich gefoltert sie haben mich
seelisch gefoltert sie haben mich
körperlich gefolter sie haben mir gesagt
du hast keine Familie niemand hat nach
Dir gefragt und die ganze Zeit habe ich
mich gefragt was ist mit meinem Mann was
ist aus ihm geworden warum kommt er
nicht und mich abzuholen die ganze Zeit
kamen sie zu mir und sagten mich ja von
wem bekommst du deine Befehle von da
drüben von wem bekommst du diese Befehle
gehört zu den Anführern bist du eine
Anführerin ich wusste überhaupt nicht
was sie meinen sie schlugen mich sie
traten mich sie erniedrigen nicht sie
haben mich beleidigt sie haben
Schimpfwörter benutzt die vulgär sind
sie haben nicht gedimmt ich habe
niemanden gesehen aber ich konnte die
Stimmen hören ich konnte die Stimmen der
Insassen hören die wie ich in dem
Gefängnis waren die Stimme die ich im
Kopf habe das war ein Mädchen ein sehr
junges Mädchen anhand der Stimme konnte
ich das daran erkennen sie hat geweint
es ging ihr sehr schlecht und sie rief
nach ihrer Mutter sie hat die ganze Zeit
nach ihrer Mutter gerufen das hat mein
Herz sehr bedrückt in dem Augenblick
vergaß ich meine Schmerz ich wollte
hingehen sie umarmen hab keine Angst ich
bin da ich bin genauso wie du hab keine
Angst ich bin da
was glauben Sie wie alt war dieses
Mädchen 13 14 15
10 18
auf jeden Fall war es die Stimme eines
sehr jungen Mädchens ein sehr junges
Mädchen und um das noch einmal zu
verstehen so einen Folterkeller wie wie
ist das hatten sie Tageslicht hatten sie
ein Gefühl für die Zeit wussten sie ob
Tag oder Nacht ist haben sie verstanden
wie spät es ist durften sie sitzen
durften sie schlafen dürften sie liegen
wie war das
gut
nein aufgrund der Schläge ich habe so
viele Schläger antalier gehabt ich habe
so viel Schmerzen gehabt ich war
benommen ich wusste überhaupt nicht ob
es Tag oder Nacht ist ich hatte keinen
nicht von draußen es gab nur ein Luke
ich habe einen Luke gesehen und dann
konnte ich vom Flur das Licht geben
sehen also ich konnte eine Tür hören
verriegelt ich konnte diese dieses
Geräusch hören und dann konnte ich
anhand dessen erkennen dass jemand rein
gezehrt wird ich konnte hören dass sie
weinen dass jemand gebracht wird
durften sie sitzen Schlafen sich
ausruhen
[Musik]
sehr schmudd dort gab es zwei Decken
zwei schmutzige decken nur darauf konnte
ich aber mich ausruhen aber als sie zum
vorher kam musste ich nur stehen bleiben
ich man hat mir nicht erlaubt zu sitzen
manchmal ging es mir überhaupt nicht gut
ich habe keine Kraft in den Füßen in den
Beinen ich konnte nicht stehen bleiben
aber sie haben doch oft bestanden sie
haben die Fragen wiederholt und sie
wollten dass sie stehen bleiben
was was tut diesen jungen Demonstranten
im
Extremfall und was wird den vorgeworfen
also was ist der konkrete Vorwurf wir
haben es gerade gehört der bankclub
verwandelt offen und die Frage war wer
schickt Dich wer sind sozusagen deine
Auftraggeber
es gibt inzwischen mehr als
18.200 Verhaftungen die Gefängnisse
bersten auseinander jeder kommt mit
jeder der nicht zum Regime gehört und
das iranische Parlament hat ja vor ein
paar Wochen schon die Todesstrafe für
alle verhafteten gefordert der iranische
Präsident Ibrahim 3 ist sie ist bekannt
dafür dass er Todesurteile als Richter
ausgestellt hat am fließt niemand hat
sich politische Oppositionelle 4000
dafür ist er mitverantwortlich an 4000
politischen Hinrichtungen insofern dass
das Regime jetzt
Todesurteile ausspricht und auch
ausführt in einer Woche zwei und noch
weitere 20 jetzt im Moment anstehen für
für Hinrichtungen die sind schon in
Isolationshaft ist nicht verwunderlich
das Regime zeigt nur jetzt sein wahres
Gesicht die Menschen sind nicht entsetzt
darüber die Menschen bleiben seit 43
Jahren im Iran unter der Islamischen
Republik die im Namen des Islam
tötet foltert vergewaltigt und den
Menschen die Luft zum Atmen genommen hat
insofern
das was zu Beginn auch eingespielt wurde
mit der Sittenpolizei das ist der
Generalstaatsanwalt meinte ist die
Sittenpolizei ist abgeschafft das ist
eine Finte es ist ein Ablenkungsmanöver
dann gibt es die Sittenpolizei nicht
mehr gibt's Übersicht mieten die sie
mitnehmen würden und sie verhaften
würden oder den Geheimdienst der
Revolutionsgarde oder die Schergen die
gezahlt wurden genau für diesen Moment
in dem und dafür hat die Islamische
Republik Millionen Milliarden gezahlt
und diesen Sicherheitsapparat aufzubauen
um genau für den Notfall
drücken Sie auf den Knopf und jetzt
kommen die Schergen auf die Straße und
prügeln die Menschen nieder und
vergewaltigen sie und töten sie dafür
haben sie ein Leben lang in dieses
System finanziert und investiert
wird gern noch eine Frage stellen ich
merke mich während das alles fällt
trotzdem würde ich gerne fragen wie
sieht das einschätzen was ja bewegend
ist ist die Tatsache dass sie wie so
viele andere einfach immer weiter
gemacht haben also sie werden in diesem
Wagen reingezerrt sie werden geprügelt
sie werden gedemütigt und wenige Tage
später sind sie wieder auf der Straße
glauben Sie das wird weitergehen wird
dieser Protest am Ende an Erfolg sein
wird es damit enden dass dieses Regime
Geschichte ist also
ja sicherlich
als dich freigelassen wurde als ich
zurückkehrte als ich nach Hause ging es
mir überhaupt nicht gut eigentlich hat
meine Seele darunter gelitten ich hatte
Angst vor allem mich hatte Angst vor dem
Geräusch der Tür ich hatte Angst vor dem
Schloss aber als ich die Stimme des
Volkes auf den Straßen hört als sich das
[ __ ] auf den Straßen hatte
hab ich das Gefühl gehabt ich bin
verpflichtet ich habe mich geschämt dass
ein 16-Jährige das Leben auf den eigenen
Händen trägt auf die Straße geht und
dass ich dann zu Hause bleiben nein ich
wollte auch etwas machen ich habe mit
meinem Mann ich habe mich hingesetzt und
habe ein Flyer aufgesetzt wir haben so
viele Flyer aufgesetzt ich habe meinen
Wut in dieser Flyer zu Sprache gebracht
ich habe das auf in diesem Text zu
Sprache gemacht wir haben auf dem
Motorrad dieser Flyer verbreitet wir
sind dann wir sind auch in einer Nacht
ich habe Angst gehabt aber wir sind
zusammen auf die Straße gegangen ich
habe den Mut der Leute gesehen ich habe
die Einheit der Leute gesehen ihre
Solidarität und das war für mich sehr
schön
das ist ein ein Video das Sie uns
mitgebracht haben zur Verfügung gestellt
haben das zeigt wie sie gemeinsam mit
ihrem Mann unterwegs sind zu einer
Demonstration
und zwar nachdem sie im Gefängnis waren
ganz neu ist ist die Menschen lassen
sich nicht mehr einschüchtern die haben
nach dem ersten Gefängnisaufenthalt sie
haben keine Angst mehr und sie rufen auf
der Straße tötet ihr einen kommentausend
nach so sie haben egal ob sie mit
Hinrichtung drohen hinrichten töten
vergewaltigen abschrecken sie sagen es
ist egal in diesem System möchte ich
nicht mehr leben
letzte Frage war nur wie groß ist die
Hoffnung dass sie irgendwann in einem
freies Land in einem freien Iran
zurückkehren können
Zusammenhalt unter der Bevölkerung unter
den Iranern Iranerin gesehen mit sie
haben nichts ihre in ihrer Hand wir alle
wir Menschen die im Iran wollen die
Islamische Republik nicht wie erkennen
die Islamische Republik nicht an die
Freiheit ist nah also
ich habe eine Botschaft darf ich den
besten eine Botschaft mitteilen
[Musik]
eine Iranerin
jemand die 32 Jahre im Iran gelebt hat
in diese Gesellschaft war alle Probleme
gesehen hat ich möchte die Stimme meines
Volkes sein ich möchte die Stimme alle
Mütter sein
die Schmerzen haben ich möchte die
Stimme derjenigen sein die gefoltert
werden ich möchte die Stimme derjenigen
sein die im Gefängnis sind ich möchte
dass meine Stimme vernommen wird ich
möchte dass die
Menschenrechtsorganisationen meine
Stimme im Namen meines Volkes hören ich
habe meinen Pass dabei das ist der
passte Islamischen Republik ich möchte
mein Pass hier zerreißen ich möchte der
Welt zeigen dass wir die Islamische
Republik nicht mehr anerkennen aus
unserer Sicht ist das das Ende der
Islamischen Republik
ich danke Ihnen sehr das war sehr
bewegend das erste Mal dass jemand so
offen über das gesprochen hat was in
diesen Folterkellern passiert und das
wird nicht ohne Nachhall bleiben bedankt
mich ganz ganz herzlich dann hat mich
ganz herzlich bei Natalie Amiri vielen
Dank Pater pollonska ist bei uns die
Butcher überlebt hat die wir bereits im
Mai in der Sendung hatten zugeschaltet
aus gab es noch freue mich sehr Sie hier
zu sehen und Katrin Eugendorf sehr
geschätzte Korrespondentin unsere Kriegs
äh Reporterin die ich keine Fragen würde
Kathrin wir haben eben zu Beginn dieser
Monat auf Cocktails gesehen diese selbst
gebauten also fing das alles an was habt
ihr gedacht Leute die so viel
Kriegsalltag begleitet und beobachtet
haben wie lange halten die durch
also ich habe schon viele Kriege und
Krisen in meiner journalistischen
Laufbahn gesehen aber das was wir in der
Ukraine
sehen und erlebt haben das habe ich in
der Form noch nicht gesehen auch was den
Widerstand der Bevölkerung angeht das
mag auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen
schmunzeln lassen und nicht so wirklich
ernst zu nehmen wirken wenn Leute mit
selbst
Molotow-Cocktails vorgehen aber wir
haben es hier wirklich mit einem Krieg
zu tun wo die Masse der Bevölkerung
hinter
diesem ja dieser Form der Verteidigung
steht also es ist nicht nur die Armee
sondern ist man erlebt bis heute dass
Menschen mit selbst den banalsten und
kleinsten Mitteln versuchen ihr Land
gegen diese russische Aggressionen zu
verteidigen
Vorschlag Zimmermann sie waren von
Anfang an jemand der sehr deutlich
gesprochen hat für die Lieferung
deutscher Waffen waren dann auch sehr
früh in der Ukraine warum
weil ich glaube dass das dieser Überfall
auf die Ukraine der ja dieses Land
erschüttert und wir haben ja die Bilder
gesehen wo umgebracht gemordet
vergewaltigt wird dass das unsere
grundsätzliche freie Welt ins Beben
gebracht hat und dieser Krieg der
natürlich vor allen Dingen die Menschen
in der Ukraine betreffen ich glaube dass
viele in Deutschland noch nicht erkannt
haben das ist da irgendwas ganz
grundsätzlich es geht um unsere Freiheit
und das Wladimir Putin das Russland uns
unsere Freiheit uns nehmen möchte
glauben möchte das ist ein Kampf der
Systeme und das zu transportieren das
ist ja kein angenehmes Thema
das habe ich mit meinen Kollegen
Kollegen zusammen immer eigentlich vom
ersten Moment an so empfunden wusste so
oft sein Joachim Gauck denken der glaube
ich in Polen in einer Rede viel beachtet
damals viel gescholten auch gesagt hat
wenn wir da jetzt nichts tun das war
nach der Annexion der der Krim dann
stärkt das den Appetit des Aggressors es
ist so und es ist interessant gerade
auch die Ausschnitte die sie gezeigt
haben von unserer Bundeskanzler starke
Auftritt am 27 Februar dann wurde es
wieder etwas ruhiger starker Auftritt
wie er selber angegriffen wird sind
immer so Wellenbewegungen und ich glaube
was wir lernen müssen wir haben in der
Tat das muss man heute sagen für über 2
Milliarden Euro auch schwere Waffen die
wirklich wirken geschickt aber wir
müssen natürlich weiter denken der
Winter kommt der Winter ist da in der
Ukraine das ist nicht morgen zu Ende und
es ist so schade dass es eben in Wellen
kommt und nicht konstant und ich glaube
dass
wenn man diesen Krieg sieht dieses
eingestehen dass die Politik unter
schließlich keinen aus der letzten Jahre
Russland gegenüber eine falsche war dass
wir Wladimir Putin auch angefüttert
haben in der Annahme dass wir uns nicht
wehren ich glaube das ist so unglaublich
fatal und es sind zwei Fronten es ist
der eine die Front in der Ukraine aber
wir haben noch eine andere und das ist
die kommunikative die in den Netzen
läuft um Europa von innen und um uns
alle von ihnen stabilisieren und das ist
anders aber genauso gefährlich und
deswegen müssen wir so unglaublich
wachsam sein Katrin was würdest du sagen
wann ist im Bewusstsein der Deutschen
auch der deutschen Politik wirklich
angekommen dass da Krieg herrscht
war das Butcher
ich glaube das Ausmaß des Krieges oder
welche Form von Krieg und das finde ich
hier das Wesentliche ist bei der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit erst mit
Butcher angekommen weil in Butcher haben
wir ganz klar gesehen das ist kein Krieg
wo es darum geht ein Territorium zu
erobern es ist auch kein Krieg zwischen
zwei Regimen sondern es ist ein
Vernichtungskrieg gegen ein Volk
ich habe das vorhin schon gesagt ich
habe noch nie Bilder dieser Art wie ich
das in Butcher erlebt habe das wirklich
Zivilisten die gerade vom Einkauf kamen
auf offener Straße hingerichtet werden
Zeichen von Folter tragen dass Frauen
vergewaltigt wurden teilweise vor ihren
Familien ähm diese Bilder zeigen einfach
welche Form von Zivilisationsbruch hier
eigentlich geschieht und von Russland
begangen wird wir haben solche Zustände
in Europa seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
nicht mehr gesehen und ich glaube was
wir noch immer nicht verstanden haben
ja das ist die Natur dieses Krieges das
ist ein Völkermord ist aber gegen wen
richtet sich das und sie haben das
gerade finde ich sehr korrekt
beschrieben die Perspektive ist meiner
Meinung noch immer viel zu sehr dass wir
an der Seite der Ukraine für die Ukraine
eintreten aber Putin hat seinen Krieg
russland hat seinen Krieg dem Westen
erklärt und die Ukraine ist nur ein
kleiner Bestandteil eines viel viel
größeren Krieges der längst schon seit
vielen vielen Jahren von Russland
geführt wird und nicht nur mit Waffen
sondern eben auch durch die
Stabilisierung durch
Kommunikation
durch die Stützung von radikalen Gruppen
wir haben das in den USA erlebt wir
erleben das auch in Deutschland wie weit
im Prinzip der russische arm ist in
Demokratien hineinreicht und versucht
sie zu zersetzen
heute bei uns und Katrin Eigendorf die
uns damals auf diese bewegende
Geschichte der aufmerksam gemacht hat
ich freue mich wirklich sehr sie heute
so auf den ersten Blick zumindest
einigermaßen gesund hier sitzen zu sehen
und bevor wir gleich darüber sprechen
was ihnen widerfahren ist eine kurze
Zusammenfassung
als Anfang März die russische Armee in
Butscher einfällt und Wohnhäuser
bombardiert flüchten die Schwangere
Hanna polonzka und ihr Mann mit dem Auto
aus Angst um ihr Leben
obwohl weiße Bänder an Ihrem Auto hängen
das Zeichen für Zivilisten werden Sie
schon nach wenigen Minuten von
russischen Soldaten angegriffen und
immer wieder beschossen Hannas Mann
stirbt vor ihren Augen
sie überlebt im siebten Monat schwanger
ukrainische Soldaten bringen sie erst in
ein Krankenhaus nach irpin später
schafft sie es in eine Klinik in Kiel
ihr ungeborenes Kind kann nicht mehr
gerettet werden
im Krankenhaus lernt polonzer langsam
wieder laufen ist jeden Tag in der Reha
und macht Physiotherapie gleichzeitig
gibt die Deutschlehrerin schon wieder
Unterricht am 14 september wird sie von
Kiew nach Berlin verlegt wo sie
inzwischen lebt und arbeitet
darf ich Sie fragen wenn wir noch einmal
zurückgehen bevor wir den Blick da noch
mal nach vorne werfen wie haben sie
diesen Moment dieses Angriffs auf dieses
Auto erlebt weil sie waren hochschwanger
sie lebten dort glaube ich in der elfte
Etage dieses Hochhauses mit ihrem Mann
voller Zuversicht zu voll Optimismus und
ein ganz normales Leben und zwar
sozusagen haben sie sofort verstanden
was da passiert der Angriff kam fünf
Minuten nachdem sie losgefahren waren ja
ich habe alles in demselben Moment
begriffen als ich total im Blut meines
Mannes war also in dem Moment habe ich
begriffen ich muss jetzt ähm
alleine für mich selbst kämpfen und ich
habe sofort gefühlt dass ich mich nicht
mehr bewegen kann und das einzige was
mir geblieben ist war mein meine Hündin
und so seitdem hat mein eigener Kampf
begonnen
seit dem 4 märz und jeder Tag bis heute
ist eine große Herausforderung für mich
obwohl ich gesund aussehe es ist noch
nicht
jeder Tag fängt damit an dass ich mir
Mühe geben muss und aufzustehen und
nicht zu fallen und jeder Schritt fällt
mir nicht so einfach wie eine normalen
Person und hier in Deutschland höre ich
von Zeit zur Zeit solche Fragen wie
haben sie ein kunstbein oder etwas
ich bin noch nicht ganz gesund aber mit
jedem Tag glaube ich
ist mein Ziel näher und näher
ich habe sie damals im Mai in unserem
Gespräch über die Distanz schon sehr
bewundert weil ich dachte vorher nimmt
sie diese Kraft woher nimmt sie diese
Hoffnung wenn man sie haben alles
verloren was ihn lieb und wichtig war
sie haben mir ungeborenes Kind verloren
sie haben mir ein Ehemann verloren sie
haben gerade ihre Hündin erwähnt und sie
sprechen immer über dieses Tier und ich
merke es ist ihm wichtig
waren sie nicht wichtig und
vielleicht war mir
das was mir Kräfte gegeben hat ja ich
habe so lange auf das Treffen mit ihr
gewartet
das einzige
was mich zu trennen
immer wieder
jedes Mal ja verstehe ich
Butcher das ist ich meine Botschaft ihr
Butcher war ein schöner friedlicher
Vorort von Kiefer und so will wir haben
Butcher kennengelernt durch
Reporter wie Katrin Eugendorf als den
Abgrund wirklich der Zivilisationsbruch
Butcher ist das Synonym geworden für
alles was furchtbar ist an diesem Krieg
die Hölle genau was hören sie heute aus
Botschaft was was hören sie früher war
das die schönste Stadt der Ukraine echt
ich habe mir da die Wohnung gekauft weil
es wirklich die schönste die ruhigste
die sauberste die beste Stadt der
Ukraine war und dabei im Vorort von der
Hauptstadt also das war wunderbar jetzt
also geht das Leben gut weiter viele
Menschen sind nach Botschaft
zurückgekehrt und bestimmt hat man
Butcher sauber gemacht aber sowieso es
gibt viele Häuser wie Mainz zum Beispiel
die noch diese
Folgen des Krieges zeigen die Häuser
sind beschossen und viele Wohnungen
brauchen viele Reparaturen würden sie
noch mal dahin zurückgehen ich
persönlich hoffe dass ich dort nie mehr
fahren werde ja ich möchte nicht und
nicht nicht weil ich da etwas Schlimmes
gesehen oder erlebt habe umgekehrt weil
ich da die besten Momente meines Lebens
hatte deswegen möchte ich dazu nicht
mehr und meine Eltern haben
Bücher mehrmals besucht also ich habe da
eine Wohnung sie wurde teilweise
ruiniert
aber und fast alle Sachen wurden geklaut
stimmt
etwas ist mir geblieben und meine Eltern
haben die Wohnung mehrere Male besucht
haben mich gefragt ob ich dorthin will
und nur zwei Sätze noch von ihnen zum
zum Schluss wir können in einer solchen
Sendung nicht so in die Tiefe gehen aber
die darf man der Öffentlichkeit nicht
vorenthalten sie sagten also in
Deutschland angekommen bin am 14
september das war die erste Nachricht wo
es ruhig war wo es warm war und wo ich
nach langer Zeit endlich mal wieder
durchgeschlafen habe dass das eine und
auf die Frage nach der Motivation woher
die Ukraine die Ukrainerinnen diese
Kraft nehmen das so durchzuhalten sagten
sie mal wenn man keine Kraft mehr hat
wenn man total müde ist und nicht mehr
kann dann denkt man daran dass es
trotzdem so immer noch besser ist als
mit den großen
100% ohne Strom ohne Heizung ohne alles
besser als mit Russen 100 Prozent und
jede Person in der Ukraine jeder Ukraine
jeder Ukraine ist mit mir einverstanden
ich habe das Gefühl habe ich auch ich
danke Ihnen sehr herzlich